[Musica]
benvenuti finanche le marchigiane mi
porto i saluti della direzione
e siccome questo è un luogo e
un'occasione in cui si raccontano delle
storie allora
volevo raccontare bene anch'io una qui
appunto al fedex sliding doors vi
racconto la storia che ha a che fare con
questo luogo anche fare con questo
palazzo con questa stanza guido chigi
saracini nasce nel 1880 con un cognome
enorme ma con un patrimonio non
altrettanto vasto quello veramente ricco
e lo zio primogenito fabio chigi
saracini comunque guido cresce con
un'infanzia in collegio
un'adolescenza nelle cerchie nobiliari e
a 25 anni
guido è un uomo che ha fondamentalmente
due passioni
una è la fotografia e l'altra è la
musica che vale qualcosa di più guido ha
studiato violino sono il pianoforte ama
chopin sopra ogni cosa scrive canzoni
canzoni che vengono pubblicate anche da
importantissimi editori in tutta europa
ed è anche un fan sfegatato di giuseppe
verdi tanto appassionato diverti da
sposare nel 1905 la figlia di un
baritono verdiano bianca cashman la loro
vita scorre felice almeno apparentemente
nel palazzo di via camollia
fino a che nel 1906 improvvisamente lo
zio fabio chigi saracini muore in un
incidente di caccia
fabio chigi saracini aveva designato
fluido chigi come unico erede universale
di tutte le sue ricchezze
quindi guido si trova ad ereditare oltre
il titolo di conte
anche il palazzo al piano con le cave il
la villa di castelnuovo berardenga con
migliaia e migliaia di ettari di terreni
poderi e fattorie e il palazzo di via di
città palazzo chigi saracini questo
palazzo qui in quel momento
guido decide che questo palazzo sarebbe
diventato un tempio della musica e
all'interno di questo tempio un cuore il
cuore il sancta santorum il salone per
ristrutturare però il palazzo
lui si chiama l'architetto artista
arthur viligiardi e gli chiede di
ispirarsi a quei luoghi che sono lì dove
è nata la civiltà della musica
strumentale italiana guarda la venezia
di vivaldi perché guido sogna che un
giorno anche l'italia possa vantare le
radici della musica strumentale come
possono fare i tedeschi con bach e per
questo appunto fa ispirare viligiardi al
settecento veneziano
solo che il settecento di viligiardi
come potete vedere dialoga anzi
amoreggia con l'art decò con il liberty
e dialoga con quel medioevo ghibellino
che il palazzo conserva ancora nascosto
da qualche parte
dunque questo è un tempio questo luogo
dove siamo non si poteva entrare col
cappello non si poteva entrare col
bastone
bisognava rispettare non si poteva
uscire finché c'erano i mussi sul palco
ma per officiare i riti di un tempio
quale può essere lo strumento migliore
se non l'organo ed ecco che guido chigi
saracini fa costruire un organo che sia
il migliore più all'avanguardia
possibile da due grandi organari carlo e
francesco veggetti bossi ma lo fa con la
super missione di un amico marco enrico
bossi che è il più grande organista in
circolazione dopo mille vicissitudini
questo organo molto complicato molto
moderno riescono a più o meno quasi a
metterlo a punto è nel 22 novembre del
1923 il giorno di santa cecilia
finalmente inaugurano questa stanza
inaugurano l'organo con un concerto
appunto un concerto d'organo per coro e
orchestra d'archi dove vengono suonate
delle musiche di jazzolino della sciaia
frescobaldi e anche una cantata composta
da marco enrico bossi esplicitamente
commissionata dal conte guido chigi
saracini ma guido chigi saracini e un
intellettuale che guarda con attenzione
alla contemporaneità e sa che appunto
qui c'è un palco dice l'organo e allora
come si fa ad officiare i riti
attraverso anche qualcosa di
spettacolare decide che insieme alla
musica di marco enrico bossi avrebbe
ballato anche charlotte bar a chi esce
allo sbaraglio charlotte da crack
una è una danzatrice nasce da una
famiglia di ricchi industriali ebrei
tedeschi in a bruxelles
subito si appassiona alla danza nel 1915
prende lezioni da alexander sakharov e
da somma dei cortili dello sun
alessandro sakharov sta in quel momento
rivoluzionando la danza il linguaggio
della danza e insieme alla moglie loro
dichiarano che la musica non va
interpretata non va animata ma va
vissuta spiritualmente è espressa
attraverso i movimenti del corpo
la charlotte bara si sposta nella comune
frequenta la comune di artisti di word
fede è fede e viene ritratta dai ris
vogler come vittima della guerra nel
poi si sposta berlino diventa
ispirazione per moltissimi artisti
berlinesi e nel 1923 gira un film dove
appunto un film intitolato le danze
gotiche di charlotte bara c'è una sbarra
si ispira agli antichi riti egiziani
antichi riti egizi misteriosi ma piano
piano comincia a interessarsi anche
appunto del medioevo e del rinascimento
italiano ha preso il nome di una famosa
reso il consumo di una famosa altra star
del cinema americano che nel frattempo
sta interpretando anzi sta incarnando il
ruolo di cleopatra se da bar
e insomma quindi il conte decide che la
bara è la persona giusta per celebrare
dei riti con le sue danze sacre e sa che
anche la bara sta lavorando su una
pantomima dedicata a caterina da siena
quindi decide la mette in comunicazione
con il maestro bossi per organizzare
questo spettacolo questo spettacolo è
bossi
all'inizio si lamenta un po perché la
bara di mano delle musiche che qui non
conoscevo le partiture lei nel frattempo
li manda altre lettere
che insomma limando limando un
repertorio di musiche e preferirebbe un
pianista perché l'organo le piace tanto
comunque le danze egizie le farà senza
musica
perché non ne sente il bisogno
sicuramente di bossi che è un
grandissimo musicista un po un po si
risente e tutto quanto questo di questo
dibattito avviene triangolato con in
mezzo il povero piero baglioni
segretario artistico del conte e
violinista ma insomma dopo tanti
dopo tante lettere alla fine si mettono
d'accordo e organizzano un repertorio
che tiene insieme le musiche di johann
sebastian bach del figlio william
friedman di césar franck domenico
scarlatti e su queste musiche la bara
interpreterà le sue pantomime le sue
raffigurazioni mimiche sacre e
cominceranno appunto come una vision
gothic e andando avanti angeli e altre
figure la madonna figure penitenti della
passione e così via
ora bossi che all'inizio non è così
diciamo non crede tanto alla buona
riuscita dello spettacolo anzi pardon
del rituale arcaico che deve essere
realizzato su questo palco
in realtà quando la bara appare su
questo palco con i suoi costumi con le
sue movenze figurazioni stati che noi
rimane completamente affascinato e
allora il pubblico è assolutamente in
visibilio e quindi decidono di ripetere
lo spettacolo è il primo giugno qualche
giorno dopo cambiano il programma
mettono altre danze preparano
velocemente questo spettacolo è
finalmente la bara potrà debuttare con
il suo ruolo in caterina da siena il i
due continuano a lavorare anche lontane
da siena fateci questa lettera che dalla
bara al conte chigi che gli racconta che
stanno lavorando insieme e spera di
poter fare una rappresentazione a roma o
anche addirittura a firenze
bossi è talmente contento di questa
collaborazione e sta per partire per una
tournee negli stati uniti e quindi
magari decide che anche lì potrebbe
essere promosso questo spettacolo il 18
novembre del 2000 e del 1924 bossi parte
per gli stati uniti e la tournée sarà un
trionfo suonerà new york
nella philadelphia questo è il più
grande organo del mondo allora esistente
wine maker e appunto magari parla di
contanti impresari per poter
sponsorizzare questo spettacolo con la
bara riportare la barra negli stati
uniti ma al ritorno nel 1925 nel
febbraio il piroscafo su cui viaggiava
il piroscafo degrassi affonda quindi
bossi muore e con lui naufraga anche il
sogno della bara il cibo ci vorrà tanto
tempo perché bossi possa essere
rimpiazzato nel cuore dell'amico chigi
finché appunto nel 1929 si presenterà
fernando germani giovane prodigioso
organista che sarà il primo docente di
organo in questo luogo quando nascerà
l'accademia chigiana nel 1932 quindi il
primo insegnamento non poteva che essere
un insegnamento di organo la bara nel
frattempo nel 1925 costruirà il teatro
san materno dall'architetto card veder
meyer che è il primo spazio
polifunzionale con mobili con moduli
mobili quindi uno spazio moderno e
questo diventerà un tempio per la danza
dove appunto si riuniranno degli adepti
che frequenteranno la danza come
esperienza finita spirituale creeranno
una compagnia come dice in poi è
diventato un po gran parte del teatro
contemporaneo
il conte continuerà a fotografare le
posture minute delle danze con la sua
macchina fotografica
oppure organizzerà pantomime come questa
nel giardino della sua villa di casanova
berardenga per la inaugurazione della
statua di chopin inviterà i coniugi
sakharov a insegnare a siena e quando
loro appunto verranno qui continueranno
i loro insegnamenti delle danze in
costume fino al 1963 quando proprio
durante la settimana di insegnamento
alexander zakharov terminerà qui a siena
i suoi giorni due anni dopo
scomparirà anche guido chigi saracini e
ci lascerà in eredità questo luogo ma
soprattutto la vita che lo anima qui
dentro hanno risuonato le musiche per le
dopo duecento anni di silenzio di
antonio vivaldi
qui dentro però sono anche suonate le
prime note importanti di compositori e
artisti che hanno fatto la storia della
musica del novecento il conte guido
chigi saracini che ha sempre tenuto
apparire come l'ultimo degli
aristocratici in realtà ha sempre avuto
uno sguardo intelligente e attento sulla
contemporaneità
tanto che oggi appunto i docenti e gli
allievi che vengono qui per i corsi si
occupano di conservare la memoria della
musica ma anche di spingersi verso
l'innovazione
perché la musica è una parte che fatta
di tempo e vive solo di presente la
musica è sempre contemporanea e allora
la storia di oggi ci dice due cose che
non c'è innovazione senza memoria perché
abbiamo bisogno di qualcosa per
costruire qualcosa di nuovo una base di
competenze ma anche che non c'è memoria
senza innovazione perché abbiamo bisogno
di riconoscere qualcosa di diverso per
capire che siamo andati avanti e memoria
innovazione sono le due le due parole
che riassumono un po la storia
dell'accademia chigiana la traiettoria
perché hanno a che fare con il presente
anche fare quindi presente il presente
del che il tempo delle scelte che sono
al centro di tutti i racconti
ascolterete oggi quindi non mi resta che
augurarvi benvenuti e buona fortuna
[Applauso]
[Musica]